[Musica]
[Applauso]
sapete quando mi sono trasferita da
bucarest a palermo avevo 9 anni era il
24 dicembre all 8 gennaio cominciato la
scuola ricordo che la mamma mia
preparata al giorno come se fosse
l'ingresso nell'alta società piuttosto
che di una scuola nuova
non mi aveva detto molto su cosa mi
sarei potuto aspettare in cambio aveva
curato ogni dettaglio estetico avrà
pensato che visto che non sapevo dire
una frase italiano che fosse almeno
piacevole alla vista già sapevo solo
presentarmi dire pizza si no
e grazie fino ad allora il mio concetto
di italiano era mettere le ha e leo alla
fine delle parole punto cielo
chiarissimo il mio secondo primo giorno
di scuola ero pietrificata sull'uscio
della porta della classe per niente al
mondo avrei voluto che la mano di mia
madre si sganciasse della mia
il cuore mi batteva come quello di un
colibrì e quando dalle spalle mi ha
spinto a fare qualche passo in avanti
mi sono sentita mancare con voce
tremolante e bocca secca
mi son dovuta presentare mi chiamo
raluca da anche aveva una classe di
bambini incuriositi e una maestra con il
rossetto rosso fuoco era un incubo
andare a scuola alle prime settimane ero
confusa e intimidita e anche se tutto
intorno a me era molto più bello
rispetto a bucarest non riuscivo a
placare la frustrazione asfissiante di
passare un altro giorno a studiare cose
incomprensibili in una lingua
incomprensibile
mi sentivo senza vie d'uscita
intrappolate una situazione che non
avevo scelto ecco l'ho raccontato questo
episodio per condividere un'esperienza
che ho vissuto e sollecitare in voi una
qualità intrinseca in ognuno di noi
l'empatia il concetto di empatia è
qualcosa di magico e la capacità che
abbiamo di immedesimarci nelle
esperienze soggettive di un'altra
persona è l'essere in un mondo in comune
per usare le parole di edith stein in
cui possiamo comprendere lo stato
emotivo di chi abbiamo
questa capacità si forma naturalmente
nell'infanzia quando inizialmente non
distinguiamo il limite fra noi e gli
altri e quando per esempio da piccolini
vediamo un bambino cadere facendosi male
iniziamo a piangere come se fossimo
stati noi a cadere ma poi per fortuna
iniziamo a distinguere i nostri
sentimenti da quelli degli altri e
iniziamo a concentrarci sui segnali che
rivelano i sentimenti le neuroscienze ci
dicono che abbiamo queste abilità grazie
i neuroni specchio che sono capaci di
riconoscere e comprendere il significato
che hanno le azioni che guardiamo perché
percepire fare hanno uno schema
rappresentazionale comune così per
comprendere il significato e le
intuizioni delle sensazioni dell'altro è
sufficiente che io possegga la
conoscenza delle mie sensazioni abbia
cioè dalle esperienze nel mio bagaglio
adesso non significa che per capire come
mi son sentita anche voi dovete aver
vissuto un trasferimento improvviso in
un'altra nazione ma basta che sappiate
cosa significa quando il cuore
accelerata la paura ho la sensazione di
sentirsi in trappola
ed è qui che vorrei rallentare un attimo
e soffermarmi sulla vastità di
esperienza che la vita ci riserva
quotidianamente nell'infanzia
vi siete sentiti amati accettati
protetti coccolati se sì in che misura
se non quanto ne avete tollerato la
mancanza mi è capitato di vivere
un'esperienza terrificante con una
persona dal temperamento violento o di
sentirvi umiliati davanti ai compagni di
gioco di vivere la separazione dei
vostri genitori e il vuoto lasciato
dall'assenza di uno dei due
questo è tutto il resto si depositano il
nostro bagaglio emotivo e le diverse
proporzioni di gioie e dolori che
abbiamo vissuto assegnano un valore alle
nostre esperienze che inconsapevolmente
diventano il filtro con cui osserviamo
la realtà noi stessi e gli altri e con
il tempo il mondo con cui ognuno si
confronta non diventa altro che la
selezione del proprio mondo interiore e
ciò significa che assume rilevanza solo
ciò che è già dentro di noi
ciò che è conosciuto in quanto a fine
problematico l'inconscio ci guida quasi
totalmente nelle scelte di tutti i
giorni determinando quello che noi
chiamiamo gusto quello che ci piace
quello che non ci piace quello che ci fa
stare a proprio agio e quello che ci
irrita li faccio qualche esempio
giulia adorava quando la nonna nelle
giornate calde d'estate le preparava il
gelato al gelsomino cannella oggi
casualmente il profumo che indossa e
sulle note del fiore e il suo colore
preferito lo stesso della corteccia
dell'albero oppure a stefano per via del
suo maestro poco rassicurante non
impazziva andare a elezioni nuoto oggi
guarda caso preferisce andare di più
montagna che al mare
ovviamente non ci rendiamo conto di
queste analogie o magari lo facciamo in
piccola parte ma inconsapevolmente
cerchiamo disperatamente delle
associazioni perché la nostra capacità
di sopravvivenza dipende dalla nostra
capacità di riconoscimento
ma il nostro vissuto non condiziona
soltanto questo il gusto ma anche le
relazioni che abbiamo con gli altri cosa
cerchiamo cosa vogliamo
come li giudichiamo perché l'inconscio
lavora molto velocemente e nella
frazione di qualche secondo in grado di
trovare l'analogia con il nostro passato
avete presente quella sensazione a pelle
che si ha quando si conosce dopo con una
persona bene la sentenza è presa in un
battito di ciglia all'interno delle
nostre esperienze
se mi trovate piacevole o meno in questi
pochi minuti non è perché conoscete le
mie azioni miei valori può essere
l'accento con cui parlo il modo in cui
gesticolo la mia postura che richiama in
voi una persona con la quale avete
passato dei momenti piacevoli o meno e
questo vale anche per l'arte che sia
figurativa o astratta non ha importanza
le emozioni che mobilitiamo di fronte a
un quadro sono essenzialmente le stesse
che mobilitiamo in tutti gli altri
momenti del nostro quotidiano e nel
rapporto con l'arte
possiamo essere stimolati a livelli
molto profondi della psiche e provare
particolari esperienze emotive
una di queste la più grande la massima è
la sindrome di stendhal ossia che il
dettaglio di un'opera d'arte come la sua
dimensione un colore l'espressione di un
volto sono in grado di gettare
inconsapevolmente un fascio di luce su
alcuni aspetti della nostra vita
scuotendo c per qualche istante e non
sto parlando di di valori estetici
oggettivi perché altrimenti davanti alla
venere di botticelli dovremo provare
tutti le stesse sensazioni ma possiamo
parlare di empatia estetica visto che
l'oggetto d'arte può farsi contenitore
di emozioni e conflitti inconsci nel qui
e ora siamo continuamente stimolati da
elementi che richiamano azioni e
pensieri che non fanno interamente parte
del presente e il colore è uno di quegli
elementi della vista in grado di creare
analogie con il passato aprendo ponti
spazio temporali noi conoscendo il mondo
aprendoci al mondo entrando in relazione
con il mondo registriamo il mondo dentro
di noi e il colore in quanto onda
elettromagnetica viene decodificato
dall'occhio è visualizzato nella mente
ma grazie a un organo di senso più
esteso che abbiamo grazie alla pelle e
le sue terminazioni nervose registriamo
ogni singola colore che ci circonda
tutti insieme contemporaneamente e non
solo quelli di cui siamo consapevoli nel
momento in cui vi possiamo uno sguardo
ma lei non siamo soltanto uno strumento
di ricezione ma anche di interpretazione
ed elaborazione e con le emozioni alcuni
colori presenti nei momenti emotivamente
importanti diventano particolarmente
significativi così un colore per
analogia può farsi carico di intere
scene di vita belle o brutte e
ritrovando le un altro contesto anche a
distanza di anni è in grado di evocare
quelle particolari sensazioni
intanto familiari il colore è innocuo ma
potente dice tutto e non dice niente
nella mia ricerca artistica mi sono
focalizzata proprio su questo
slittamento temporale che può avvenire
tra uno stimolo oggettivo presente e
l'aggancio emotivo con il passato dando
vita dei lavori che per me sono a tutti
gli effetti di ritratti ritratti però
che non raccontano i segni che il tempo
ha lasciato sul volto non raccontano il
sesso
l'estrazione sociale all etnia ma
attraverso campiture di colore puro
raccontano quelle esperienze che hanno
contribuito in maniera significativa
alla creazione della propria identità in
chiave analogica l'opera è un poligono
irregolare composto da altre figure
geometriche regolari e ogni componente
come la sua di come la dimensione
piuttosto che i colori scelti sono
elementi che il soggetto ha registrato
nella sua vita ogni colore incarna una
situazione perché era fisicamente
presente in quel momento e per arrivare
a queste informazioni che solo il
soggetto possiede ma non è a conoscenza
usa una tecnica ipnotica che mi permette
di portare il suo inconscio a galla e
capire quali sono questi colori
il ritratto e il mondo della persona e
la raccolta ma non la definisce la
espone totalmente ma non la mette in
pericolo la confronta con le altre ma
non la contrappone a nessuno un ritratto
non ha un significato predeterminato non
è nulla in particolare
ma evocativo e moltissime direzioni così
il soggetto si riconosce a pelle e
diversi fruitori sentono differenti cose
con caratteristiche atmosfere secondo
cose il loro passato ha predisposto a
sentire è più una questione di eredità
emotiva piuttosto che di capacità
immaginativa e quello che senti non
quello che vedi l'anno scorso non sono
andato a intervistare alcune persone che
nel loro quotidiano soffrono di certi
pregiudizi socialmente diffusi che li
inquadrano in strette etichette
limitando per certi versi la loro
libertà
e ve li voglio far vedere voglio
proporvi una sorta di gioco
una sorta di test proiettivo e ecco io
che li guardate abbastanza velocemente e
capire se in questa espressione non
conforme alla fisicità andando oltre i
nostri figli logici riusciamo a trovare
e ad avere un terreno in comune con i
soggetti ritratti
quindi guardateli velocemente poi ci
ripassiamo sentite quello che vi piace
di più quello che vi prende come una
sensazione di pancia
allora questa è una persona con
orientamento buddista questa è una
ragazza gay
questa è una persona con l'orientamento
musulmano narcotrafficante un prete una
persona che soffre disco disturbi
schizofrenici uno scienziato in mezzo
che non c'entra sul pregiudizio è un
uomo gay e questi sono praticamente
nella loro dimensione
allora con chi avete qualcosa in comune
se poteste parlare con la persona che
rappresenta sentire se come la vaga
sensazione di conoscerla già nella vita
di tutti i giorni
l'empatia che proviamo nei confronti
degli altri è estremamente condizionata
dal nostro grado di pregiudizio e non
perché siamo brutti e cattivi
quanto perché ignoriamo certe dinamiche
che ci governano ma essere maturi
significa riconoscere con gentilezza che
nelle relazioni che abbiamo con gli
altri possiamo essere coinvolti in
molteplici proiezioni inconscio e quindi
etichettare nell'altro come fastidioso
in realtà non è altro che quella
quell'atto di noi che in fondo non
accettiamo
ovviamente non siamo responsabili degli
eventi della nostra infanzia da dove le
nostre proiezioni derivano ma in quanto
adulti
oggi abbiamo la responsabilità di
capirne la natura e non sto parlando
solo di una comprensione intellettuale
ma di un sentire personale che esige di
uno sforzo di consapevolezza e dentro
questa consapevolezza si può scorgere
che l'esistenza i suoi dilemmi le sue
ferite le sue attese e le sue mancanze
sono comuni a tutti siamo franchi
siamo fragili in questa nostra
condizione umana siamo tutti per abbiamo
tutti paura di non essere accettati di
non essere riconosciuti nelle nelle
nostre debolezze nel nostro bisogno di
ascolto e di aiuto ma la fragilità fa
parte del nostro destino e se riusciamo
a cambiare anche di poco il modello con
cui interpretiamo le relazioni le
persone che incontriamo non li
incontriamo senza una ragione noi siamo
la vita degli altri veniamo sfiorati e
in questo modo possiamo accompagnarci
per mano verso una migliore versione di
noi stessi anche se il colore ha tanti
significati come quante le persone che
sono al mondo
il colore è l'essere in un mondo in
comune con tutte le persone del mondo
grazie
[Applauso]